foreign
[Music]
Jacob from from the crash
where my mum's grave bed by night
roll with the punches my granddad used
to say
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
chalk one up for team living
I'll huff and I'll puff and I'll blow
your house down
foreign
[Music]
Jacob from from the crash
my granddad used to say
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
everyone good
Jax
you got a little
yeah I figured you're one souvenir pair
the edges YouTube
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
so this is where David Rothstein lived
The Man Behind Hollywood's worst video
game movie adaptations and those
live-action game trailers gave people
unrealistic expectations I hate those
you two know the drill super room make
sure no one's home
this could be our new safe house
to the day at the office [ __ ] nice
office
[Music]
I'm getting it
well that was easy
imagine how much below this surface has
seen
it's always snowing in L.A
kitchen's clear
what are you doing seeing if anyone's
been shopping
[ __ ] Hollywood
I don't know if this is expired milk or
some free range green tea kombucha
[ __ ]
vigoration coffee to start today
hey guys check this out
classy [ __ ] huh
seems like a real down to earth dude I
hope you didn't make it why because he
turned on your dumb half man half horse
rom-com screenplay centaurs man I told
you centaurs
can't even much of a producer if you
couldn't see Hollywood's next billion
dollar franchise
clearly
move on Ponyboy
it's clear anyway
how's that for doesn't fall out of a
clear 3x structure
di2
I wonder
Jackson come on just one sec
foreign
[Music]
I hate to tell you but you picked the
wrong time to come to town
bet you thought your world was in chaos
try this on for size
bitten infected somewhere between alive
and dead God why are they turning [ __ ]
doesn't get more real than this
Los Angeles
City of Angels or as we like to call it
hello
just think of it as your own stylish
sunbaked zombie smashing playground and
trust me these hungry bastards are
everywhere
but don't worry
there's more to this city than Hours of
Happy skull busting it's crawling with
Adventure and crazy ways to pass your
final days
we've got all the usual tourist
attractions
albeit with a uniquely horrifying vibe
there's loads of survivors you want a
blast on a train special
although we're getting the pizza they're
all as mad as the flesh eaters
[Music]
seems they like you a lot Jacob
I'll take it from here
we've all dreamed about smashing zombie
brains right
whether you're slicing kicking stomping
burning
or whatever it is you're gonna really
feel it I guess dreams do come true
and [ __ ] man you'd be amazed at what
these angelinos keep in their Hollywood
houses
Tana's machetes swords hammers bigger
hammers are those bear claws and
naturally a holy [ __ ] ton of guns
if that doesn't do the job DIY is always
your friend
too awesome
oh and that zombie bite
came with a little pop of Z power
which is always handy
freaking zombies these reanimated
[ __ ] come in all shapes and sizes
big ones
little ones Smart Ones no not new dubby
noisy ones I hate them was once even
pretty ones you really can't knock their
stuff
except for this guy back for more huh
[Applause]
hey Different Strokes for different
folks right as long as the dead stay
dead
foreign
what do you say
see you in hell
not at all surprising
looks like Ross in was uh into a bit of
directing too
I wonder how many young actors got their
big break right here
the old boy sure was adventurous we've
got voyeurism
golden showers
pegging classic
and uh mummification
everything was on the menu with this guy
except centaurs
I reckon 50 50 chance this is spiked
wanna roll the dice boss
small
the usual
nah I'm good pretty sure Rudolph can't
hurt anybody now but uh this could
come on YouTube
hey Brad
clear boss
here boss
you're kidding me
Dead Island two we'll hear coincidence
huh what do you mean finding a video
game set in a zombie apocalypse when
we're in a zombie apocalypse
huh
life imitating art
anyway
let's see what this is about looks like
I'm going for a smoke then
what's Alexa game control
how about I find out for you no chance
hey zombie get over here
hang on what happened I don't know
come on
come on
uh you might want to find a weapon
guys give me my ax out here
it's like you've played this before
[ __ ] it time to go local
[Applause]
how are you doing this
get him
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
you gotta see this
thanks for the help guys
quit your bitching let's get back to it
now
not to get anyone's hopes up unless
there's some kind of feral zombie
commune hidden in these walls we might
have found the greatest Safe House in
L.A we're not safe here yet
safer here in Santa Monica hope here was
Secure look what happened there like
ants on a popsicle stick exactly at
least here there were four walls and
enough booze for you two to be
entertaining especially considering
there's no one else here
let's do a second sweep the entire Place
gotta be sure
white dudes tend to stick around way
longer than you think
there aren't any
news here and as far as rosting goes
he's dead probably eaten by a zombie or
choked to death on one of his dildos I'm
no expert but I'm going with dilda so
let's just say this place is secure and
get on with happy hour
it's secure when I say it's secure now
come on let's finish this
Brad you coming
this keeps getting worse
I don't know if they can come back from
this
something funny
come back to what
a city hit the rock bottom long before
the outbreak [ __ ] maybe for you turn
up here on the idiot bus screenplay in
hand but for actual locals like me
La had character character
really
the city was the capital of [ __ ]
people over and ripping their hearts out
at least now folks are being honest
about it that out there that's la
finally showing his true character no
longer hiding behind an inflatable
plastic smile while sucking out your
soul
look Brad I don't mean to offend you man
I know your whole family is dead and all
but
think about it like this you're alive
free free from rejection free from be
Lilman free from the [ __ ] Rat Race
that plague this terrible City and the
douchebags the second fans the rostings
of that
debt nowhere to be found
you were saying Jay right you were smart
should we shoot him he's got no chance
out there and I ain't sharing a bathroom
with him in here close the door
not the best time I know but I took your
notes on board page one rewrite maybe I
can hold these guys off while you're
reading huh
who's that Ward up
[ __ ] I survived I'm losing my touch
[Music]
they're gonna be a thousand riders in
here no on this project
time to go to work
[Music]
what a bloodbath
never seen so many before
so many that anyone who didn't see us
fight them
probably won't believe that we actually
did fight them
what we did
totally did
fight them
what now I didn't grab that aisle too
piece of [ __ ]
party's over
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
thank you
[Applause]
I got it come on
[Applause]
[Applause]
everyone good
Jax you got a little
yeah I figured you're one souvenir here
are the edges YouTube
[Applause]
[Music]
so this is where David Rothstein lived
The Man Behind Hollywood's worst video
game movie adaptations and those
live-action game trailers gave people
unrealistic expectations I hate those
you two know the drill through every
room make sure no one's home
this could be our new safe house
for the day at the office
a nice office
[Music]
I'm kidding it
well that was easy
imagine how much below this surface is
seen
it's always snowing in L.A
kitchen's clear
what are you doing seeing if anyone's
been shopping
[ __ ] Hollywood
I don't know if this is expired milk or
some free range green tea kombucha
[ __ ]
cigarettes and coffee to start today
hey guys check this out
classy [ __ ] huh
seems like a real down to earth dude I
hope you didn't make it why because he
turned on your dumb half man half horse
rom-com screenplay centaurs man I told
you centaurs
can't have been much of a producer if
you couldn't see Hollywood's next
billion dollar franchise
clearly
move on Ponyboy
room's clear anyway
how's that food doesn't fall out of
clear 3x structure
di2
Jackson come on just one sec
[Music]
foreign
I hate to tell you but you get the wrong
time to come to town
bet you thought your world was in chaos
try this emphasized
bitten infected somewhere between alive
and dead God why are they turning [ __ ]
doesn't get more real than this
Los Angeles
City of Angels or as we like to call it
hello
just think of it as your own stylish
sunbaked zombie smashing playground and
trust me these hungry bastards are
everywhere
but don't worry
there's more to this city than Hours of
Happy skull busting
it's crawling with Adventure and crazy
ways to pass your final days
we've got all the usual tourist
attractions
albeit with a uniquely horrifying vibe
there's loads of survivors you want a
blast on a trip special
although we're getting the pizza
they're all as mad as the flesh eaters
[Music]
seems they like you a lot Jacob
I'll take it from here
we've all dreamed about smashing zombie
brains right
yeah
whether you're slicing kicking stomping
burning
or whatever it is you're gonna really
feel it I guess dreams do come true
and [ __ ] man you'd be amazed at what
these angelinos keep in their Hollywood
houses
Tana's machetes swords hammers bigger
hammers are those bear claws and
naturally a holy [ __ ] ton of guns
if that doesn't do the job DIY is always
your friend
too awesome
oh and that zombie butt
came with a little Papa Z power
which is always handy
friggin zombies these reanimated [ __ ]
come in all shapes and sizes
we got big ones
little ones Smart Ones no not new dummy
noisy ones
the cake that was once even pretty ones
you really can't knock their stuff
except for this guy
back for more huh
[Applause]
hey Different Strokes for different
folks right as long as they're dead
stay dead
[Music]
so
what do you say
you in hell
[Music]
not at all surprising
looks like Ross scene was a bit of
directing too
I wonder how many young actors got their
big break right here
the old boy sure was adventurous we've
got voyeurism
golden showers
pegging classic
and uh mummification
everything was on the menu with this guy
everything is absent ours
I reckon 50 50 chance this is spiked
on all the dice boss
the usual
nah I'm good pretty sure Rudolph can't
hurt anybody now but uh this could
come on YouTube
hey Brad
clear boss
here boss
you're kidding me Dead Island 2 weird
coincidence huh what do you mean finding
a video game set in a zombie apocalypse
when we're in a zombie apocalypse
huh
life imitating art
anyway
let's see what this is about looks like
I'm going for a smoke then
what's Alexa game control
how about I find out for you no chance
foreign
get over here
hang on what happened I don't know
come on come on
you might want to find a weapon
guys give me my ax
like you've played this before
[ __ ] it time to go local
how are you doing this
get him
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ] yourself
foreign
you gotta see this
thanks for the help guys
quit your bitching let's get back to it
now
not to get anyone's hopes up but unless
there's some kind of feral zombie
commune hidden in these walls we might
have found the greatest safehouse in L.A
we're not safe here yet
safer here in Santa Monica hope here was
Secure look what happened there like
ants on a popsicle stick exactly at
least here there were four walls and
enough booze for YouTube to be
entertaining especially considering
there's no one else here
let's do a second sweep the entire Place
gotta be sure
white dudes tend to stick around way
longer than you think
there aren't any
news here and as far as rosting goes
he's dead probably eaten by a zombie or
choked to death on one of his dildos I'm
no expert but I'm going with dilda so
let's just say this place is secure and
come with happy hour
it's secure when I say it's secure
now come on let's finish this
Brad you coming
this keeps getting worse
I don't know if they can come back from
this
something funny
come back to what
the city hit the rock bottom long before
the outbreak [ __ ] maybe for you turn
up here on the idiot bus screenplay in
hand but for actual locals like me
La had character character
really
the city was the capital of [ __ ]
people over and ripping their hearts out
at least now folks are being honest
about it that out there that's la
finally showing his true character no
longer hiding behind an inflated plastic
smile while sucking out your soul
look Brett I don't mean to offend you
man I know your whole family is dead and
all but
think about it like this you're alive
free free from rejection free from
belailment free from the [ __ ] Rat
Race that plague this terrible City and
the douchebags the second fans the
rostings are that sad
it's dead nowhere to be found
him
morons you were saying Jay write yours
should we shoot him he's got no chance
out there and I ain't sharing a bathroom
with him in here close the door
not the best time I know but I took your
notes on board page one rewrite maybe I
can hold these guys off while you're
eating
water
who's that Ward up
[ __ ] you survived that wasn't my touch
[Music]
[ __ ] you're gonna be a thousand riders
in here
time to go to work
[Music]
[Music]
what a bloodbath
never seen so many before
so many that anyone who didn't see us
fight them
probably wouldn't believe that we
actually did fight them
what we did
totally did
fight them
what now I didn't grab that aisle too
piece of [ __ ]
party's over
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
come on
[Applause]